hey is Cameron Fiat from gamma labs
vanadium corporation would tell us about
three problems in computable probability
theory thanks very much so the things
that I'm going to be talking about today
are joint work and various combinations
with Nate Ackerman who's here Jeremy oh
my god dan Roy who will be speaking on
somewhat related things on Thursday and
Jason route ok so I'm going to talk
about three problems there's somewhat
related each of them is either an object
or a result in probability theory for
which we're going to ask about the
computable content so you can view this
as a collection of results in what some
people call computable analysis and it
also each of these problems has some
direct relevance to probabilistic
programming languages and their
semantics and various questions related
to those so the first thing we're going
to look at is definitely serum and
specifically the mixing measure
sometimes called the defen Eddie measure
then we'll talk about a higher
dimensional version of it Aldous Hoover
kallenberg theorem which is also related
to graph limits if you're interested in
that perspective so this is dealing with
exchangeable two-dimensional arrays in
the case that will look up and then the
third example of the problem that we're
going to look at is related to
conditional probability distributions
and specifically the disintegration map
that can be used to form conditional
distributions so some of these are
positive results cases where we're able
to get objects that are computable even
in situations where it's not obvious at
first and then some of these are
negative results will show the non
computability and in some cases
calibrate now ok so first we're going to
look at definite ease theorem and so
I'll start with an example of an
exchangeable sequence but described in
encode so this example should be
familiar to some people in the
probabilistic programming community or
also maybe who've seen it in a
statistical context so this is sort of
invented Python probabilistic
programming language here so the idea is
here's one representation which is
inherently sequential and uses state
I'll walk through what this does and
then I'll show you another
representation that gives
essentially the same thing in
distribution but it's a rather different
way of computing it ok so we're defining
a function here called next draw there's
some global variables sum and total and
then we flip a coin with the weight
determined by the ratio some in total
and increment some counters and return a
value so what's going on here is the
standard employer earn where we start
with in this case one red ball in one
black ball let's say the sum is the
number of red balls and the total is the
number of redd+ black balls and the way
this urn works is we choose a ball
uniformly at random from the urn we look
at it we write down either 1 or 0
depending on its color is the next
element of the sequence then we put it
back and we also add a new one of that
same color so over time this is going to
drift towards what the ratio has been so
far roughly so here's one example of the
sequence of calls to next draw ok so we
get some sequence of zeros and ones
here's a picture of this path so we're
just plotting total versus some so this
is sort of showing over time the state
of these two variables for the sequence
of next draws that we saw above which is
incrementing these global variables
here's a different run I haven't shown
the separate 01 sequence but there's
some other sequences zeros and ones that
gives this blue sequins and there's a
key property here that that will come
back to which is that both the value of
sum and the value of total are the same
at the end of each of these runs even
though they had different intermediate
values yeah I wonder centex Albert so as
a next draw yeah we did the same
direction so are you a favoring the zero
and one final outcomes the same
direction previous oh well so so some n
total are so some is sometimes
incremented and hurdles o is incremented
so they both increase as you call next
draw so when we get 0 then that means
that total is increased but not some
then on the next one we got a 1 so now
they're both incremented so they both
tend to increase over time
to be more than half of the total yeah
probably get one yeah exactly so so the
ratio with which we get ones tends to
drift to the current ratio where at the
beginning it doesn't matter as much but
eventually after we've seen quite a
large number of zeros and ones then it's
very difficult to have long run
frequency be other than what it's been
so far right so conquest to a media
reader should converge to 0 the ratio
between some and so that no it's more
complicated than that so here's a
picture of what happens with with a
longer run so this box here is zooming
out from this original here so this is
what happens when this red run is
continued and one possible sequence coin
flips and here's blue continued so they
both go through the same point there as
we observed but so they both have the
property as I said that there's a long
run limiting ratio and in fact with
probability one that happens to an
infinite sequence of drawers but the
particular slope it turns out you can
show is oya analyze that that's
uniformly distributed so uniformly
between zero and one is the distribution
of the limiting slope which almost
surely exists for this particular
example so it's a little bit surprising
ok so so this is what's going on with
that example this is a sort of standard
sequential representation of the poi you
earned now I'll describe it in a rather
different way but if what I just said
what I disclaimed is true then this
should give the same distribution so
here we first draw outside of the
procedure a uniform random variable
theta just once and then next draw has
access to theta but it doesn't use any
state it doesn't change any state itself
it doesn't store anything at the end of
its run it just independently each time
draws Bernoulli with weight theta so it
turns out you can show that these have
the same the same distribution over
sequence of next rose so you might think
this is a one-off case but in fact
definitely CRM which I'll describe in a
moment says that in fact whenever you
have some possibly sequential
representation that has the property
that the sequence of random values you
get is invariant in distribution to
rearranging the terms as you can show
for this then in fact there has to be
representation essentially like this so
I'll make that more precise now ok so a
bit more formally we'll talk about a
sequence of real random variables that
you can do this in a polish space
without too many modifications so we say
it's exchangeable if for each n and
every permutation of 1 to n the
distribution of the Joint Distribution
of the first n terms of the sequence is
the same as the permeate distributions
the Joint Distribution of the / muted
terms in the sequence ok and I you might
wonder about whether this holds your
infinite permutations in fact that
that's automatic by coma gorph
consistency but we don't need to worry
about that in in any particular finite
run but in fact that that's true and so
definitely serum says the following are
equivalent so the sequence is
exchangeable it has the symmetry
property if and only if the sequence is
conditionally id given some random
variable theta so here this was that
uniform random variable in general this
is going to be something like a random
measure you can think of in that case
it's a random Bernoulli where the we
just specified the random parameter
explicitly and a third representation
will give yet another in a slider too so
a third representation is that the
entire sequence the infinite sequence is
equal distribution to the following
sequence of function calls so there's
some function f deterministic function
such that when you give it uniform
random variables as inputs where the
theta is shared across all of them and
the UI's are different so these are each
marginal uniform and they're all
independent from one another then this
is equal in distribution ok so that's
essentially what was going on in the
second representation we had this theta
that was being shared across all of them
and each of them used some well the
uniform that they were using was sort of
implicit in the coin flip it could have
been something more complicated but
there's always a representation of that
form
abstractly this doesn't mean that
there's necessarily a computer program
to do it but but this is what the
theorem is saying are there any
questions about this so far yeah
previous example is changing oh yes if I
had one sequence that have zeros and
then half once yeah so so what you can
show in the case will pull you earn a
key property that implies
exchangeability in this particular case
is that the probability of any
particular prefix is determined only by
the number of zeros and the number of
ones so if I tell you what sum and total
are you can tell me the probability of
that sequence you don't need to know the
particular order 0 1 0 1 0 1 so that's
just go get it like one half you can
roughly right each time oh well it's
more complicated because the the coin
flip each time depends on this value
that's drifting closer for the same it
turns out they're the same so there's a
calculation to be done that I'm not
doing but but yeah it turns out that
they're the same I mean there's may be
other ways of describing this that make
it more obvious i'm not claiming it's
clear in this case but it happens to be
the case you can write down for example
a closed form and then then it square ok
so right so we're sorting that that this
is exchangeable and this is a sort of
instance of definite ease theorem but
I'm not claiming that you could have
found this automatically is it just
happening to be the case okay but then
the question that we're going to look at
is when you can actually drive something
on the right from something on the law
okay so I'll just pause for a second to
know an additional interesting property
maybe more from either statistical or a
programming language point of view which
is if we if we consider these sequences
as represented in the two different ways
as graphical model or Bayes net what's
going on here with the conditional
independence ease that are implied by
these arrows is that the sequential
representation we generate y1 using some
randomness then y2 conditioned on y 1
again uses some randomness and then y 3
it depends on the value of y1 and y2 in
print
and again uses some randomness and so on
so it's a very complicated conditional
independent structure in the sequential
representation whereas quite explicitly
in this either this Third Point or just
the conditional independence is stated
explicitly number 2 saying there's some
random variable condition on which
they're all independent so this is some
sort of shared object such that once you
know that can be computed in parallel
these are rather different structures of
the computation even though it turns out
they're the same in distribution so
informally we might say that using the
function f we can sample the variables
why I in parallel okay yeah proceedings
like what happens if she start with a
different proportion of four red and
okay yeah so that's a good question so
it turns out that if you start with any
value of some and any value of total
that are I guess positive and when total
at least the value of some what you're
going to get over here is the beta
distribution of appropriate parameters
in terms of these so if you start with
our red balls and B black balls and it's
beta of our be so I guess in this case
it would be beta of some comma total
minus some so it happens that beta of 11
distribution is uniform on the unit
interval which makes it sort of simpler
to describe this but but not only is
there a limiting long-run frequency with
probability one but in fact the
distribution of those limiting long-run
frequencies itself has a nice closed
form in terms of these two parameters
which don't even have to be integers
baby may one way to address the seeming
paradox you are seeing is that if you
conditioned on so these two paths that
red and blue end at the same point they
have the same probability but there are
many more paths that have kinks and
there's only one path that has only one
kink so I think you're you're kind of
latching on to the fact that it's rare
to see to how to end at that point and
go flat and then then come up the
zigzags engl in that line yeah so some
some of these pictures are more common
if you consider various simple rotations
of them to be the same picture but still
in aggregate
yeah but they're all equal in
probability right so if I think about it
this is a mark mark of Markov process
essentially what you convinced us is
that any any distribution that stable is
a stable distribution is a Markov
process between 0 & 1 values of the
variable Y you have two states right
then any any probability on these two
states is a stable stable probability
distribution of this Markov of this
Markov process because if there is
probability and in the 0 and with the
probability 1 minus v-0 in one then your
family there this is exactly the same
probability solution for the next for
the next round so it's a stable stable
distribution just an observation only in
the limit yeah so this yes so this state
is the limiting value but it doesn't
literally appear at any point here like
if you stop this at any given fine at
point so the conditional distribution of
the next term like that predictive
posterior is is determined by just that
initial prefix time T plus 1 is quick
depends only on it's not Markov and
stuff my cocaine because you have to
look at all the things that happened
before it's conditionally Markov
condition on this variable its marked
off but it that variable doesn't even
exist over here and it's implicit but
yeah so so then the question is whether
we can move between the representation
on the left to the representation on the
right I mean first of all does it even
exists a computer program and secondly
come uniformly find it and the answer in
this case is yes so this is some work
with dan roy from a few years ago and
sauce a bit more about the notion of
computability that's relevant here but
the claim is that the distribution of
the exchangeable sequence this the joint
distribution of the infinite sequence is
computable an appropriate sentence if
and only if there's some computable f
can be found uniformly in Y such that
these are equal and distribution as in
the phonetics theorem and so the claim
is that in this case the hidden parallel
structure can be automatically recovered
in a way that exposes the conditional
independence even though as we'll see it
involves some limiting quantity which is
not obviously computable and you might
worry that you could code the halting
problem into it and in fact and some
higher dimensional cases that that does
happen as we'll see okay so let me just
tell you a bit about what these notions
of computability are these aren't going
to define things carefully enough for
some people perhaps but hopefully we'll
least give you some intuition for a
bunch of different perspectives I should
say while all these different notions
coincide in the case of computability in
the case of complexity theory they often
bifurcate in interesting ways so some of
this goes back to work of de loup more
Shannon and Shapiro in the 50s where
they started looking at notions of
probabilistic Turing machines and and
what notions of computability could look
like for randomized computation the
formulation when i'm going to subscribe
is essentially due to Schroeder in early
2000s and the computable analysis
community in this virus tile type to
effectivity and there's also been a lot
of work in domain theory and elsewhere
that's given essentially the same
characterizations so just to make this
concrete let's say we have a real random
variable and let's say f here's capital
f as a distribution function then
equivalent notions of of this
distribution being computable are that
the probabilities are computable in the
sense that this cumulative distribution
function is computable at points of
continuity another is that expectations
are computable for a computable function
from real 201 which implies that this is
continuous with a uniformly computable
modulus of continuity and another is
what you might call computable
simulation this is saying that we can
compute early build random variables
that have the appropriate distribution
so one way of formulating this is that
there's some function from you an
interval thinking this is our sort of
basic probability space to the reals
such that when you plug in a uniform
unit interval random variable to H the
distribution that you get out agrees on
a measure one set with with the
the distribution in question so or sorry
yeah agrees and distribution with with
say the initial random variable and so
here it's a central that it be
computable on a measure one set it might
be not just that it disagrees on on
measure 0 but that it doesn't even halt
if you imagine what's involved in well
so this is in terms of the uniform you
could also formulate this in terms of
counter space say let's see if the
sequence of coin flips and you're trying
to build Bernoulli of one-third random
variable there just are going to be no
matter how you do it there will be at
least one sequence of zeros and ones
that you're not going to be able to
compute ibly assign a value to from
videos 201 you mean on their Nationals
as a student computer for a sort of no
no so here I mean something so you can
think of this is say a continuous
function whose whose modulus of
continuities is uniformly computable or
you can think of it in terms of say lazy
real arithmetic I give you an interval
that the inputs and you give me
increasingly tight intervals on the
output and so on so so this you can take
to be total in a way that this random
variable might not be that it doesn't
actually eat step computable well it
will turn out it is so it what I mean
here is that there's some program
describing h in say in terms of this
interval arithmetic and it happens that
it converges on measure 1 and
furthermore with measure one that agrees
with the original so it's only going to
be able to have like it's not all things
that be something like a pie to that or
something like it can't actually be an
arbitrary function if if it's being
described by the I program but yeah
Jake's ocular rationals so
just but i think i shared with coke
yawns confusion about why the notion of
computation is here but it's just I just
don't know there are sort of
competitions that being used so I mean
there there could be say accountably
infinite set of points on which it
diverges I mean in even simpler cases or
just imagine your distribution function
is the the union or let's say you have
point masses a geometric distribution on
some uniformly computable set of values
right so so actually to take your
example you could have geometric
distribution on the rationals under some
enumeration and then you're going to get
the discontinuity exactly the rationals
but that's fine I mean that is the kind
of thing that we can write all the time
in computer programs and you know you
will it is a reasonable notion of random
computation I think which which
furthermore agrees with a lot of things
that we do welcome now you might say
this is stronger than we need that this
sort of agreeing almost everywhere is
more than we need to practice on the
fact we'll come back to that at the end
of a weaker notion which devices for
some of the cases where you actually
can't get something so strong
uh yes uh yes I mean here we I'm not
sure there's a particular real that's
computable but yeah I mean it computable
real in this census is yeah but I mean a
computable real here is one for which
for example we can uniformly give some
rational that's within to the minus on
of it or we can give a sequence of
nested intervals that converges to it
there any any of these equivalent
notions okay so we'll say that a random
variable is computed leadest rib uted in
any of these equivalent cases and that
it's law is a computable distribution
and in fact this can be extended to
random variables in all sorts of other
reasonable topological spaces including
things that are a little bit more exotic
like will in fact need to talk about
computability definitely like the space
of probability measures on the reals
under the week topology if we're going
to talk about about a distribution on
unreal is being computable will need to
have that notion but this is in fact not
only a natural notion which things line
up but as with this Third Point it's
exactly what we need in practice to be
able to sample the arbitrary accuracy in
in the appropriate technology ok so
here's a somewhat different formulation
of different at ease theorem which is
going to be more useful for our purposes
so so let's say we have the exchangeable
sequence here I'm calling x instead of y
so the sequence is conditionally id
given or so definite says that if it's
exchangeable then it is conditionally id
given some random variable in fact which
we can take to be a random measure will
call it new and so one way of writing
that is that the probability that the
sequence lies in some morale set on say
reals to the Omega conditioned on this
random measure is equal to the infinite
product measure almost surely and
moreover this random measure new is
almost really unique in fact we can even
write a closed form for it that agrees
almost everywhere and so this is exactly
this limiting frequency that we saw
before but generalized to the real say
so before we were saying that the long
run frequency of zeros and ones
converged
is the ratio of those the only
interesting burrell sets on a 2-point
space are saying how many ones how many
zeros you have but in general take some
Grell subset of the reals be and count
how many times x1 through XM land there
take the the average of that for a fixed
on that limit exists so most surely and
in fact if you collect up that
information that precisely describes
burrell probability measure or a random
measure rather and that random measure
is exactly an object conditioned on
which the sequence is ID moreover equal
to the infinite product ok so if you
used to seeing things like this before
in the surgical literature then this
will be familiar if not don't worry
about it too much but this is is a
formulation that's going to be useful
for us for us talking about the
computability of it and so the
distribution of new so new is a random
measure and its distribution is a
measure on measures a probability
measure on probability measures on the
reals and that's what sometimes called
the mixing measure or the definite
measure of the sequence acts so to take
an example that's a bit different from
from the poet our emphasis starting from
the other side what would it mean to
start with the measure on a measure and
then get an exchangeable sequence from
that well that's the easy direction
which you don't need definite ease
theorem let's say we have a bag of coins
you need some distribution on coin
weights we reach through the bag pick a
coin flip it infinitely many times that
entire process it's obviously
conditionally ID I mean conditioned on
that coin way it's ID it's also easy to
see that it's exchangeable right and
more generally what this is saying is
that the only way that you can be
exchangeable is if there is some bag of
measures that does this so you might
have a random measure on the reals that
you pick out of your bag and flip that
in a sense of sampling it conditionally
Heidi but that's the only thing that can
happen so that's clearly exchangeable
deafen HTM says that's the the only way
that can happen ok and so the result is
saying that the mixing measure of an
exchangeable sequence is uniformly
computable in the sequence so hopefully
I've given you a taste of what at least
being stated here i'll describe very
briefly one of the ideas and the proof
before
moving on to another topic yeah so what
I mean by uniformly computable is it's
not just that if I give you an
exchangeable sequence it has an
exchangeable MIT sorry egg that if I
give you a computable exchangeable see
once it has a computable mixing measure
is that there's a single program that
given an appropriate representation for
example the code on the left it
generates the code on the right so a
single program does that not just it
happening to be computable in each case
let down okay so so I'll just give you a
brief sense of this and move on so one
of the the key ideas that's going on so
we're starting with the kind of thing
that we can measure initially are these
through sequence marginals given some
some sequence of sets a 13 k we can ask
what's the probability to increasingly
high accuracy that x1 lands in the first
set and x2 lens in the second set and so
on up to xk landing in the case that is
essentially the interface that we're
given we're given a program but we're
not going to be able to do a whole lot
by some sort of static analysis of it
but by running it and paying attention
to how its randomness is consumed we can
accumulate that information to ever
greater accuracy and so and by classical
definition theorem we do know there is
some random measure new sampled from
this distribution on measures mu that
we're trying to find such that the
excise term given new is distributed
according to new so there is this new
here such that this is equal to this
quantity but what we need to do in order
to recover the definitely measure the
mixing measure which classically is
equal to this but which could be very
poorly behaved so this object here I
mean if you try to get explicit bounds
on it you see that while it does
converge in the limit it's not at all
obvious it's just like pushing the
problem down to another layer to ask for
uniformly computable bounds on its
convergence but what we end up being
able to do is is approximate to ever
greater accuracy certain mixed moments
of the distribution so we have random
measure and here this set a is
representing some interval in general
let's say we have some finite union of
intervals what suffice is to determine
mu is to know to increasing accuracy the
Joint Distribution on the what the
random measure assigns as its value to
all of these all of these potential sets
a and you might think that because so is
essentially computing an expectation
with respect to this indicator function
of the set a and you might think that
this expectation is is straightforward
to compute for example by a virus Ross
approximation though even that this
virus trucks approximation the
polynomials is essentially in terms of
these quantities here but it turns out
to be not that simple because in order
to get an arbitrarily good bound on on
this integral well some of the terms in
the polynomial are going to be positive
coefficient some are going to be
negative coefficients you'll again have
something that converges but without any
control over which direction and so it
turns out that one way to do this and
the way that we first showed this was
essentially to work with virus dross
approximations that you're guaranteed to
have below at all points and so in that
way you can get sort of computable
innumerable lower bounds on on these
integrals and it turns out that that
information suffice is an aggregate
because of how these quantities all have
to sort of sum to one appropriate sense
so getting arbitrary good lower bounds
that you know are all lower bounds
devices Thanks ok so I'll now move on to
the second problem which is quite
related to this just talk for a couple
minutes and then then move on to some
some words about the final problem so
the second question is also about
conditional independence in fact in a
higher dimensional generalization of
this problem so at first we were looking
at sequences why I say and the symmetry
was exchangeability which by definition
is saying that the Joint Distribution of
the of all the coordinates is equal
distribution to a permitted version of
it you could do an analogous thing for a
two-dimensional array there's not
to natural notions already which have
been known in the literature is separate
and joint exchangeability so you can
think of this is say some relational
data you have a two dimensional array
maybe representing random values of the
binary relation symbol and so separate
exchangeability is saying that there's
two different permutations or possibly
different and apply them on the two
coordinates so essentially per meeting
the rows one way I'm per meeting the
columns and some other way still that
distribution will be invariant joint
exchangeability is asserting that only
with respect to the same distribution
pie here so this is an appropriate
notion of exchange ability for something
like an undirected graphs adjacency
matrix the separate exchange abilities
may be more relevant for something like
a bipartite graph or just a general
relation okay and so if we take a look
at the adjacency matrix of an undirected
graph here exchangeability is actually
extremely natural so in the sequence
case you have an exchangeable sequence
when there's actually some symmetry
property right maybe you describe the
sequence sequentially but it turns out
that the order didn't matter but unless
you actually just had a bag of objects
that you were forced to label in some
way you might not start with something
that was naturally exchangeable but but
in the case of higher dimensions is
actually very natural if you have a
graph that's not labeled then someone
says well you have to label it to work
with it in our framework and you say
well I don't care about the labeling
they choose any labeling well you might
want to do this in a random way so that
the labeling just doesn't matter as was
the case originally and so so if you
have say a graph here we only care about
its isomorphism type here's the same
graph up to isomorphism but if you look
carefully you see the numbers are real
abled these are the pictures of the
adjacency matrix with the zeros of in
replaced by white squares and the ones
by black so it's it's kind of
complicated compared to the
one-dimensional case in that we have to
consider these two essentially the same
object because they're related by by
this permutation and I won't say more
about about this now but it turns that
that exchangeable graphs if you haven't
encountered them they're they're used
all over the place in Beijing
nonparametric statistics and various
machine learning models as well as in
various contexts of you know
if I separately exchange about enjoy the
exchange of us so so here this tau need
not have any relation to PI so saying if
you permute the coordinates or the rows
and you permit the coordinates of the
the columns you get the same thing and
distribution joint exchangeability is
only assertiveness with respect to the
same permutation okay so the oldest
Hoover Carol Berg theorem or this part
is is due to all this and Hoover
kallenberg later showed not look all
those Hoover showed this for higher
dimensions beyond to also in kallenberg
for unbounded arity relations and
various other things that we use a
simpler case here so so you recall for
exchangeable sequences we had this
representation that made the conditional
independence explicit and for the higher
dimensional case this is also essential
what's going on there's there's some
function such that a bunch of ID random
variables when plugged in give you the
same thing in distribution here the
picture is quite a bit more complicated
I don't have time to go into tons of
details but let me give you some sense
of what's going on so let's say here we
have random variables arranged in an
infinite array so this goes on in both
to the right and down and if we look at
the graphical model structure the Bayes
net structure of conditional
independence for sequential
representation it might look something
like this which is even more horrific
right let's say you first generate this
you know if it's generated sequentially
in the sense that like x que el could
depend on lower values than k and lower
values and l or something like that and
what you'll the Sutra theorem is saying
is that this kind of conditional
independence is going on so these are
the random variables that are each ID
and independent sorry each ID uniform
that I didn't mention before but here
there's some theater which is shared by
everything and there's some randomness
that each term can use on its own like
for that coin flip in the initial
example but then there's also separate
randomness for each row in each column
which are shared across the row and
column so again it's easy to see that
this is conditionally ID and not too
hard or almost definitionally and it's
easy to see that this is jointly
exchangeable or sorry separately
exchangeable in this case but but in
fact all the super is
during that give it an exchangeable ray
it must have a representation of this
form with the conditional independence
apparent okay so the question again is
can we find this representation and hear
the answer is a bit more complicated so
no is the answer in the same notion of
computability that we had before and the
sort of object along with Jeremy avocado
and Jason root that that we constructed
is something whose adjacency matrix from
a distance looks like this in a certain
sense so I mean should actually go
infinitely far in both directions but
what I mean by this is that if you
sample an iid sequence of locations on
each axis here and look at the induced
graph that is the random variable in
question so what is this construction
one way of viewing this a bit more
intuitive than just writing that
equation is sort of infinite sequence of
questionnaires for each user which we
think of as a row and the column and the
case question is to the K possible
answers and we add an edge between any
two users if there's some question for
which their answers agrees so you might
agree on the first question which has
two answers you might also agree even if
you don't agree there on the second
question which has four answers or on
the third question which has eight
answers and so on so this is how we can
start this object but it's pretty
straightforward to show that this object
is not almost everywhere computable
there's not going to be some computable
function that agrees with this I'm
everyone essentially because given two
questionnaires you can't accurately
check and find out time it's essentially
a topological instruction in the sense
that there's no even almost everywhere
continuous representation of us on the
other hand as this construction
pseudocode pretty clearly demonstrates
its computa bleed asst tributed as an
array essentially because if you want to
get an arbitrarily good approximation
you just need to go some finite number
of questions out depending on what
accuracy you want so approximating this
function suffices for sampling
this function half here that's implicit
in this picture knowing it to a certain
approximate accuracy of in a way that we
can compute ibly do does suffice for
sampling it and so this is sort of gap
between the computability of the two
sides the representation here now the
sort of silver lining here or the an
alternative weaker notion than this AE
computability which which does hold here
of the representation when you have a
computable sequence at least in the case
when so there's a somewhat technical
assumption I'm not going to get into
here but if it comes from essentially
subsampling a picture here that's black
and white which is not the fully general
case then the distribution of
exchangeable array is going to be
computable if and only if there's this
weaker notion of computable that applies
to the representation f so here so we'll
say that function is computable
measurable you can think of the initial
notion of a computability is essentially
taking continuity and asking for an
effective zation of that in that sense
this is an effective ization of
measurability if you think in terms of
say littlewoods principles so here we're
saying that uniformly in any positive
epsilon f is computable on a set of
measure at least 1 minus epsilon but as
you change that salon even though
there's a single program that uniformly
does this in terms of epsilon as you
change that so on the answer it gives
might not agree entirely with the answer
gave before okay so this is a weaker
notion it turns out and we can recover
it in that sense and that is essentially
what suffices for for sampling in
appropriate cases and so so the end
result here as to how computable we can
represent the F here in this higher
dimensional case so for sequences it's a
computable but for arrays it's not
always a computable and sometimes even
under additional nice technical
assumptions it's merely computable
immeasurable which says in a certain
sense that a notion of approximation is
necessary for capturing some of the
structure that you might want to
represent for example in a probabilistic
programming language so it's an
interesting question that that I won't
return to much here but maybe then we'll
have more to say about or have
chat about if people are interested in
ways that this might play into language
design it this is sort of weird or
interface this computable measurability
even though you might consider it
sufficient for your purposes it's not
the usual way that we're thinking of
building randomness into a programming
language where you give the accuracy
that you want threaded through the
entire program but it might allow us to
do certain sorts of transformations on
code that we couldn't do otherwise okay
and it turns out that exchangeable
arrays that don't have in almost every
where can people left do appear in
practice not just in that sort of
pathological example and so I won't say
a whole lot about this but there's
certain points in innovation on
parametrics literature especially where
you do get an almost over computable
after than other natural cases where you
don't and in fact if you look closely at
the literature you can sometimes see
where this notion of approximation is
creeping into the sampling procedures
that people have for these objects okay
so I'm going to conclude with just a
couple minutes about this third problem
and so conditional distributions
everybody's familiar with this at some
level but in the case where you're not
conditioning on a positive measure
discrete event it's a little bit more
complicated to say what you mean even
though there are various canonical ways
of looking at it this is a sort of way
that that kallenberg frames it in his
book which I find kind of nice you can
think of conditioning as giving an l1
linear operator with certain properties
on averages it's also an appropriate
project hilbert space projection you can
also if you're familiar is right on
nicotine derivatives you can view it
nicely in that way and then the
perspective that that we're going to
look at is disintegration so the idea is
you can essentially decompose things
into a product measure that you
integrate against one of the sides so
let's say you have a joint distribution
represented on a rectangle you wanted to
sin agree against one of the sides by
saying if i give you the value on that
edge you give me a distribution for that
strip of the rectangle such that even
though it could have some measures your
wiggle room and what it reports in
aggregate all the answers you report
give you back the right thing upon
integrating an arbitrary set so
now there is this issue that things are
only to find up to null set and once
you're in this realm you need to be a
bit more careful about what you mean by
by getting the the correct answer but
but often people work in a setting where
things are much more canonical and one
thing that people sort of tacit ly
assume that it is often the case is that
there's some version of this conditional
distribution that is continuous so you
might be able to wiggle on a measure
zero set to get a really pathological
instance of it but there's some way of
changing measure 0 sets as you get a
continuous version and even in that
context it turns out that conditioning
can be quite difficult than involve some
some limiting operations that allow you
to quote up the halting problem so the
more basic operation so also along with
Nate Ackerman we looked at conditioning
on say the interval squared a pair of
computable random variables for which
the conditional distribution is is not
computable and then in this approximate
sense this computable measurable sense
or if you had appropriate noise two
random variables rather then you can
sometimes get computability and then
there's a more technical result that I
won't say much about but if you do
restrict to the case where there is a
unique continuous disintegration this
setting that I was saying is actually
quite common if not explicit in the
statistical literature then there's a
sense in which this problem is uniformly
equivalent to to a sort of jump operator
like the halting problem in an
appropriate computable analysis setting
and in the sent in a setting where you
don't have this you can also say some
things about it being about its bed is
the halting problem so I just tell you a
little bit more about these these first
two results so so the first one saying
that you have a pair of computable
random variables and in fact you can
even take them to be absolutely
continuous the obstruction is not is not
lying there such that the Joint
Distribution is computable but the
disintegration map in the sense of the
function taking a single point to the
conditional distribution of one variable
given the other equal to that point is
not computable and this is the sense in
which I meant the adding noise allows
you to
computer so if for example you have some
additional computable random variable
sign here independent and absolutely
continuous then then this conditional
distribution this is the notion of like
an approximation to the conditional
distribution now you might say okay
that's great that's all I care about but
I claim that that's actually not what
you care about in some settings at least
because it just can't help if you
actually care about this original object
a corollary immediately from these two
is that you of course couldn't calculate
a bound on the approximation error
introduced by relaxing this condition to
to the one with known as so if you can
do this and you can't do this and you
care about the first one well then this
is perhaps less consolation you might
think okay so just a picture of the
object this is not absolute continuous
that you can make it so by changing it
this is just simply to describe so this
is all the code where a halting time of
the entering machine is sort of code up
here so you know it is making use of
recursion and and lots of programming
language features at some level but it's
very simple set of random variables so
what's going on here is we divide the
square representing the Joint
Distribution up into strips the level of
gray is the density roughly speaking and
what's going on here is that we run the
0th Turing machine until it possibly
halt so we run it for some number of
steps if it halts after that finite
number of steps we immediately make this
tiled pattern with density two-thirds
and for thirds respectively with to the
K pieces if it halts after Kate steps so
this one for example halted after h2
after three steps and hence there's
these eight pieces this one you can't
tell if it halted after a very long
number of steps or if it never halted if
a never halt to make it gray but in fact
you can show that you can compute early
sample this in total even without
answering the Alton query because
essentially to compute like integrals of
an arbitrary rectangle you just need to
know it approximated in that sense and
so on down the line and then the key
property is that if we look at a single
vertical slice of this well that's going
to code up the halting problem as a
simple calculation shows so basically if
you if you look at any value other than
a dyadic rational and you take a look at
the slice down there you just read out
whether or not it halted by whether you
find two thirds or four thirds versus
one the density in this region say if it
didn't halt okay so this is a sort of
encoding the halting problem again maybe
we don't care about this particular
pathological object but this also means
that if you're interested in for example
extending a probabilistic programming
language to a setting where you hope to
be able to do conditioning automatically
you're not gonna be able to do it in the
fully general sense you might you know
as in all sorts of you know static
analyses looking for halting programs
and so on you might be able to carve out
an increasingly rich set of special
cases that cover a lot of what you care
about in practice but you just can't
hope to do it uniformly in the same way
that you can in the positive measure
kiss okay and I won't say anything more
about about these uniform results except
to say that you can essentially do these
constructions in a way that rather than
building a single example it shows that
the problem of computing conditional
distributions generally is about as hard
as that example demonstrates and so
there's some interesting technical
notions that go into it and I'll skip
that for now so thanks for your
attention and I have a brief
advertisement after that so if you're
interested in prob elastic programming
semantics there's a workshop at poffle
this year in Paris a number of people in
the room attended last year when I was
in st. Petersburg that was the first
year and actually quite a few people
this week are even on the program
committee there to page extended
abstracts due at the end of this month
so if you're interested I'll have some
fliers out during the week or come talk
to me or I'll be tougher or Dan or any
number there's quite a few people who
have been there before or around the
program committee so I encourage you to
take a look at that thanks
kept them so you showed that several
cases when you can complete the the
dissolution and ready to complete a
solution was computable you don't have
any sort about the complexity of
computing this distribution yeah so it's
something that we've looked at a bit so
it seems that the complexity of the
particular procedure that we give is
probably pretty horrendous but that's
not to say that every possible way is so
so what's going on here we end up using
very high degree polynomials to get any
sort of reasonable accuracy on on these
moments in this sort of intermediate
step and so so this particular
construction is probably going to yield
really horrible bounds but it might be
possible to do somewhat better in
general there's there's things that
we've looked at guess there's no
particular result to report there's
there's not even a simplified version of
this that Dan had boiled down and and
Scott Aaronson described on his blog a
few years ago a very simplified setting
with binary sequences it's just sort of
a cute puzzle in complexity theory and
even that it seems is is open so but he
gets a question that that we're
interested in and I mean there's some
hints in the statistical literature from
sort of classic bounds like Gretzky q4
Wolfowitz about like how quickly this
quantity converges and things like that
which you could interpret is saying
something about sample complexity but it
may be of something to do yes so we
don't know so Cameron presented to
notions of computability one where you
produce an exact sample that's a
computable and another version where
you're given a tolerance parameter
epsilon and you produce an approximate
sample so in the latter notion under
some additional assumptions like for
example if I tell you that mixing
measure concentrates on a finite set of
points then we know the complexity is
the same but we don't know if it's the
same if I demand that you produce an
exact sample so like a
beautifully measurable so AE computable
and completely met compute ibly
measurable overlap in a sense if you
take epsilon to be literally zero so it
seems that it could be impossible to get
the complexity to be the same if epsilon
zero but we don't know but that's wide
open and you certainly wouldn't want to
run in practice the particular thing we
describe I mean now 10 pages of the
paper amount to something that you could
in principle right as code that provides
a sort of funny you know compiler trick
or you know implementing this code
transformation to get the parallel
representation but you certainly
wouldn't want to do that in practice as
the current wisdoms actually the
beginning that there is a connection to
graph limits and verse for us we have
been since the beginning of the program
we had a lot about graph leaving from
yeah Agnes's retire yeah so it's this
setting here with all this Hoover and
you will hear a bit more about the
connection between graph limits and all
the super theorem at least in some sense
of the ohana patel's talk which was
going to be today and is now scheduled
for Thursday but yet the general picture
of what's going on I guess it's also
somewhat implicit in in this picture
here yeah yeah so you can view this as
as a graph on so when I was saying take
an ID sequence of locations on the unit
interval and look at the induced
adjacency matrix on those that's
essentially an instance of sampling from
this as a graph on so what's going on
with with all the suver is this
representation here is kind of a
complicated way of writing the graph on
object so if you used to thinking of a
so the general statement is that if you
have an exchangeable graph which is
jointly exchangeable array in this sense
then you can write it as a mixture of
sampling procedures over graph ons for
some distribution on graph on so the
ergodic case is a single graph on the
example and the general case is a
mixture of them and the graph on that's
lurking in here is the one so if you
look at this you see the graph on
sampling procedure in disguise because
what's going on here this theta a
is the mixture over possible graph ons
the well in the joint case these these
are used so you have these you eyes
which are the location on the interval
you're sampling from and then the
randomness that's here is to implement
the coin flip to do the Bernoulli of W
of uiuj so this is essentially the graph
on sandwing procedure so what happened
was all this in Hoover discovered this
in the setting of rays and then and then
lovas legatee and others rediscovered
this in disguise in in the case of
looking at graph ons but yes so if
you're interested in how this mapping
works there's a very nice survey by
Dakota San youngson from a few years ago
maybe two thousand seven or two thousand
eight that sort of build the dictionary
between these two perspectives is
exchangeable sequences and conditional
independence the saints no there's the
different concepts opry or e1 is is a
priori quite a bit stronger than the
other which is what makes one direction
of definite ease theorem surprising so
if we look at this version here right so
exchangeability is just this invariance
to permutation conditional independence
is saying there's some random variable
conditioned on which there are
independent and so if you have a
conditionally independent sequence like
if I told you I have a bag of coins and
that's how I generated it it's easy to
check that that must be exchangeable but
different ages they are missing that's
the only way you can be exchangeable
is there a is there anything you could
say when you don't require all
permutations have been variants and are
all permutations let's say some subgroup
of the symmetric group yes yeah that's a
great question so this is something that
has been called partial exchangeability
or there's various other notion so going
back quite a ways I mean first of all
you can even view the higher dimensional
case as an instance of this maybe like s
infinity cross s infinity sitting inside
s infinity if you sort of force the
sequent force the array into a sequence
but but yeah different different sub
groups have been considered explicitly
over the years people looked at X fear
achill symmetries you get some
representation in terms of gaussians and
there's various other specific results
and then more recently there's been work
including by Nate Ackerman and others
that look dead x general statements like
all this hoover for the case of like
close up groups of s infinity and things
like that he's done a relation between
this definity theorem and and that
family of results and mounting Gill
conversions yes I think the there are
some proofs of definite ease theorem
that explicitly write down a bargain
Gale and use Santa merry guilt
convergence theorem I guess one into
that that is implicit here when I said
you could first check that the limiting
long-run frequency converges almost
surely that the slope oma surely is
defined and so some proofs have definite
serum some of the less abstract ones
begin by showing that you almost surely
have the limiting slope and then use
that to construct the rest of the
measure
thank you very second